[Music]
all right let's go to baltimore maryland
now where jayla joins us jayla how can
we help
oh good afternoon how are y'all doing
well we're having a blast what's going
on with you jayla
thanks for taking my call um
i'm currently a sophomore in college
debt free due to a scholarship and i pay
nothing but
i'm somewhat restricted into one
business school mind you i've always had
a passion for
automotive and mechanical engineering
throughout middle and high school
due to my fear of debt
and making my parents proud i took the
scholarship rather than going to the
university i've always wanted to go to
um and my question is should i stay at
the university i'm at
due to my fear of death
or go to the university i've always
wanted to for the major i naturally have
a passion for i don't want to end up
regretful and unhappy in a career path
that i'm good at but do not enjoy one
bit yeah
well first of all young lady um
i sense a little bit
maybe you're beating yourself up a
little bit because because you did this
thing you're like i made this choice to
make mom and dad happy and to not go
into debt and i you're a sophomore in
college so you are not at this
crossroads where you've wasted any time
or effort i just sense that on you is
that true
yeah okay but don't can i ask you a hard
question jayla
well let me let me piggyback what ken
said i've never heard anyone
in all my years of working in college
saying you know what i'm really mad
about my free undergraduate education
i'm so kicked off about it what an idiot
and um so you have a passion but you
mentioned something that's a red flag
for me after working with college
students
do you really
not want to do business
and do automotive engineering
or
do you have your eyes set on a
particular university
that may have a particular person or two
or three that go to that that's the
question what's the answer
well yeah i knew it
i knew it wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait okay wait wait i think it's the
right question doc but i want to know
because you said at one point you've
always had a passion for automotive
engineering and then it was this we
heard twice this universe that i want to
and you're absolutely on it so jayla
where is it at is it 50 50 is it 60
percent university 40 engineering where
are we
it's more so like
60 engineering and 40
university because the school i go to
now they don't have an engineering
program at all okay okay so that's who
made it all right so we have very
limited time so we're going to cut right
to the chase okay
because the heart of your question is do
i have to stay where i am in a
scholarship for a degree i don't want or
take on debt and that's a false
narrative yeah yeah okay so i want to
head that off here's what i teach and
john agrees with me
you need to do the engineering work or
you will regret i mean you've you've
nailed this at a young age that you
don't want to be in a career and wake up
at 35 and go i didn't do the thing i
wanted to do you like solving mechanical
problems you like cars and the whole
automotive thing that's where you want
to be you've identified that but here's
the deal how many different pathways are
there to that future that's the homework
assignment that i'm going to give you
because you can answer that better than
i can but do not assume that you've got
to take debt on to get there because
that's garbage and it's not
true you hear me
yeah so here's the question you gotta
ask
what degree do i need or do i need a
degree and i think you do to do the
engineering you need a degree so
who are all the people that offer that
because let me just tell you this
anybody that's going to hire you jayla
is not going to care where you got your
engineering degree from am i right john
most of the time yeah
i set you up to where you just had to
disagree they don't care nobody cares
they want to know if you can do the job
so jayla it's where else can i get it
you can't get it where you are you're
gonna have to have a hard conversation
with mom and dad because i know they
want you to to go to school but you're
gonna say i'm still going to school but
i got to change my plan so where can i
get it how much is that going to cost me
how do i save up for it maybe can i get
a scholarship for that i'm going to work
as hard as i can to get into the school
i need to to get the degree i need to do
the work i want to do no you can do this
no death that's a false narrative you
got this jayla thank you so much for the
call